from burger king to starbucks here are
the highest calorie items and meals in
the u.s in the uk
we compared on the show this is food
wars
[Music]
if you were to order a venti caramel
frappuccino from a uk starbucks
it would contain 426 calories 61.1 grams
of sugar and 117 milligrams of caffeine
harry your frappuccino's looking a
little sad there buddy looks like all
your whipped cream melted so
here's a pro tip from the usa
470 calories 74 carbs
73 of which are sugar and 120 milligrams
of caffeine oh yuck
yuck that's what that tastes like
well in the uk six inches of meatball
marinara comes in at 492 calories
in the u.s six inch meatball is only 430
calories
yo am i even in the shop when i look at
the camera
well in the uk a crunchwrap has 578
calories
but shockingly it has 60 of your daily
saturated fat allowance
in the us our hexagram is 530 calories
and is about 6 grams of fat less than
the one in the uk
but surprise of no one ours has more
sodium
as is always the case in the us you have
to look at the beverages this right here
is a large mountain dew baja blast this
is 30 ounces of a liquid
that is the most unnatural green i've
ever seen it glows in the dark it's so
bright when i close my eyes i can still
see it like when you look at the sun
this beverage has over 420
calories that is ridiculous i gotta take
a sip
my body just took a screenshot that is
ridiculous that anyone drinks more than
an ounce of that ever in their lives
apparently people like drinking it it's
very popular this
has roughly 110 grams of sugar
ahem for the people in back 110
grams of sugar that's way too much sugar
for a human being to have in a week
it's an absurd amount of sugar oh god
it's like it's horrible yet i'm addicted
to it
a large whopper meal the whopper itself
is 627 calories
our 180 gram serving of large fries
would be 437 calories
and a large coke would be 209 calories
that brings a total of a large whopper
meal in the uk to 1273 calories
and in the u.s burger king the whopper
meal comes in at a hefty
1 600 calories
[Music]
if you are trying to eat healthily at
mcdonald's it might actually be the
drinks that you have to look out for
that's nothing guys our chocolate shake
840 calories that's as many calories as
two cheeseburgers
and one hamburger if you were to walk
into a uk mcdonald's and order yourself
a large big mac meal with a milkshake
it would be around 1400 calories and if
you were to get
the large big mac meal with the
chocolate shake in america the total
here is
1870 calories
[Music]
if you were to walk into a uk kfc and
order a three-piece meal and they gave
you a drum
a thigh and a wing with a large fries
and a large pepsi
that would come to 1155 calories
our large fry is 930 calories and our
large drink is 380.
and if you were to order a three piece
with a large fry and a large drink in
the u.s
it would be roughly this many calories
[Music]
let's compare large cheese pizzas in the
two countries
this is what a uk large cheese looks
like and this
is what a large properly cut domino's
cheese pizza looks like in the u.s
it's cut into 10 pieces and each slice
contains 176g calories
that means that in total the pizza in
the uk is 1760 calories
instead of 10 we got 8 slices that means
each slice
is roughly 280 calories which makes the
whole pizza
2 240 calories and according to the
thing that was written for me
that is almost 480 calories more than
the uk large
so a plain cheeseburger regular fries
and a chocolate shake for five guys in
the us
totals at 2 767
calories yo dog also i think this is
about 70
the same meal in the uk well that comes
to a total of 2769
2 calories more than in the us
well in the uk that's a large stuffed
crust pepperoni feast
if it is 10 slices each slice is 292
calories
bringing the total to 2920
one of these pizzas contains more than
double your daily sodium allowance
and more than triple your saturated fat
allowance if you want to have even more
calories in your pizza
then you got to go with the most
calorific pizza on the pizza hub menu
and thank you connor that is of course
the meat lovers
this entire thing is 3760 calories
400 of your daily saturated fat 400.
[Music]
in the uk it's a sausage and pepperoni
pizza
now for an xxl version of this pizza
each slice is 355 calories
that brings the total to 4260 calories
most calories pizza take one papa john
knows
in the u.s if you're going for most
calories it's a tie
between the meats pizza and the
pepperoni
sausage and three cheese pizza each
pizza is roughly
410 calories per slice and since it's 10
slices per pizza
that is a whopping 4 100 calories per
pizza
both these pizzas look like a nightmare
i mean
there's a lot of meat on this pizza
especially this one right here this
is exhausting just looking at this thing
so of course i'm gonna take a bite
no no